hello everyone
and this is live from frankfurt germany
rational science the only site that does
real genuine science physics
specifically let me tell you what we
want to do today
i'm going to do a little recap of the
month first of all
and then i'm going to follow that by a
little bit of an introduction there it's
going to extend a little bit i'm going
to try to shorten it
then i'm going to answer some of the
questions people or comments that people
asked and made this past week
or since last time and then we're going
to open up the
floor for questions okay with my son
here hans
my youngest son okay hi guys
my brightest of sons hey guys
[Laughter]
okay let's start with a recap okay let's
let's get going here
uh this is what we did this uh since the
beginning of the uh
i'm gonna blot you out uh since
uh january um we discussed
very briefly whether philosophy is part
of science okay
and the answer is yes but we have to
redefine philosophy in such a way that
it
uh is limited to explanations okay so
that's
the issue there does math have anything
to do with science
the answer is a flat no
mathematics can only describe an
equation
is only a description a description of
what of motion
even when you describe a square what
you're really doing is describing an
itinerary
around the square okay so
math is only a description of motion and
science we don't describe motion
or anything what we do is explain a
mechanism
a consummated event uh many nobles have
been awarded for quantum
okay discussed that in quite a bit of
detail
but can the mechanics the quantum
mechanics uh
folk explain any invisible intangible
phenomenon
uh rationally uh a particle being a two
places at once
i think that says it all okay if you can
explain that well
my hat's off to you no nobles
awarded for relativity until recently
for 70 years for over 70 years no
nobles were ever granted for general
relativity means since the birth of
general relativity yeah no no no no
since the birth of the
nobles uh relatively general relative
didn't remember
special relativity starts really uh with
einstein
not even with it starts even before the
uh it goes to the
end of the 19th of the 19th century
1889 you have
uh fitzgerald who's criticizing
michaelson morty experiment which was
which said there is no ether
and fitzgerald was a george fitzgerald
he was a pro
ether fellow and he couldn't accept that
so he tried he started with a length
contraction
that was followed by more um
formal paper by lawrence
and lawrence um he comes in 1892
and from there on you have other people
who enter the
the discussion among them einstein 1905
with his fourth paper on the movement of
bodies can't remember the whole title or
something like that
and uh and others have published papers
around the same time
by the time you get to 1915 that's when
you get
general relativity which encompasses
special relativity so since then or even
be
before that since 1900 1900 no nobles
awarded for over 70 years
makes you stop and think all the nobles
were awarded for inventions as we cover
that
and also for quantum mechanics
particles um so the question there
are black holes dark matter dark energy
space time big bang
alternative realities uh holographic
universe are any of those a part of
science oh what's the point
oh and the answer and the answer there
is
no uh because
um those are simply
irrational explanations for mathematical
descriptions
so the mathematical description we have
no problem with you know they
they do their equation they describe
motion that's fine it's the physical
interpretation of their equations
which is what you see there that's the
problem there okay
and finally is technology a branch of
science or related in any way the
science
and i'm going to discuss that a little
bit today
so i was just wondering what's the point
of saying that there was a
large span of time where general
relativity didn't get any nobles
what's the point of that because there
was nothing to give a noble for
not really not totally you have to
really put in the right context and this
is the context okay
the context is that you have in 1915
schwarzschild
he comes a german guy who died in the
war he died
a few months later he comes up with his
paper on black holes
he says you know uh calculation because
this
already the notion already existed since
the days of john mitchell
in the 18th century that you know a star
could collapse to zero size
uh or could not withhold its um
it could not fight against its gravity
okay if it was big enough
so they they had this notion that in
their head when einstein comes with his
equation
suarezel uses the calculate equation to
calculate that
yes indeed you know a star will collapse
uh to what is known today as a black
hole and that's the first starting point
then you've got
chandrasekhar indian guy and he worked
for
arthur eddington who was his boss you
know in england
and he told them hey you know a star
actually does collapse the zero size
here's the equation
and both eddington and einstein said
you're crazy
no such thing and i think that's why
they never gave a that was
in the late 1920s so they never gave a
nobel prize
at least until that point then for the
next 20 years well you had the war in
between you have
other stuff going on you don't get to
the nobles for
relativity until and this is just
a very loose interpretation
until 1967 when you have hans bethe
and he talks about how a sun how a star
produces
energy uh light okay heat
and you say well what's that got to do
with relativity well
he was trying to show that how you
create hydrogen atoms
see we could all explain with his
equations
we could explain how helium and anything
above helium comes into being
what they could not explain how hydrogen
came into being who made that god
and so the issue was you know how does
he how does that enter the picture
he said well if we go all the way to the
big bang and at the time they had the
notion already of the big bang since
1929 since they found that
the universe was expanding or so they
thought they took the film back they
said we end up with a big bang the
little ball that started it all
and so you know when you have the
situation they had the idea of big band
they said there's the only place where
you can find the energy
the energy to you know the the pressures
to create a hydrogen
protons and electrons and later on atoms
okay so that's how it enters the picture
through the big bang but he was really
trying to show you know that it's
how a sun worked how star works okay
anyways uh
let me get on with uh technology we're
gonna have lots of questions uh
probably today and i i i want you to
hold up questions until later
this is this is a i was listening to
watching
a documentary the other day
and it's about people who shun
technology
we talked about whether technology is
part of science or not
and and whether it enters the picture of
science at all
okay and the answer is no because you
got to define the terms technology and
the term science
once you define those terms you got to
be straight and keep you know
what what's in each group okay but here
you have a group of people who have
technology at their disposal and they
don't use it all
okay and they're known as the mennonites
okay
and we have amish and men and ice
there's relatively little difference
between them the difference
you could say is that mennonites uh are
more willing to
embrace technology than are the
amish but they also have limitations
okay i don't i don't see
so much of a dividing line but you'll
see in a minute that yeah there is a
little bit of
a line between them okay okay so here's
uh
the parts from that documentary some of
you probably watched it
at one time or another and the first
thing i want to point out here here's a
teacher
in one of their classrooms and the first
thing you see is a plastic bottle and a
plastic bottle cap
with coca-cola or some other uh pop in
there
and the question is uh you know it's
like that's very selective
uh apparently um they do accept some
technology
these are the amish or the mennonites
these are the mennonites but you can see
that uh it starts out with a guy you
know
uh with with a bottle and that bottle
was not manufactured
neither the coke in it by the amish
believe me okay
or the mennonites okay moonshine not
not cold yeah
maybe it was but uh they shun uh
completely alcohol okay unlike me
um here's another um piece of technology
that you would think you would not find
in an
amish or a mennonite farm and it's a
tractor
and the guy's driving it so they
prohibit
they forbid anyone to use a car but here
you see
a device that was not made in the amish
farms believe me please take my word for
it
okay it's got a motor and the guy's
driving it
in the farm uh you would think that all
these people would be still
you know with a plow in the cow in front
or the bull or whatever
uh no they do it with tractors and you
say hey that's kind of selective
uh you accept that you don't accept
other things
so you try to wonder what their
philosophy is if you can make sense of
it
also technically a type of technology
it's just outdated exactly why didn't
they do it with their hands
i mean that would be correct but instead
uh they have the the bull or the
ox pulling on on the uh plow and that's
cheating you know that's
that's cheating against god i guess um
okay uh they they kick people out who
who even try to use technology here this
fella he's a doctor you can see all his
uh uh
doctoring things all his that's that's
their pharmacy
and uh he was kicked out because he used
the phone
and the guy said he needed the phone
because there are ex
emergencies like someone's in trouble
and they have to get him to the hospital
so he said he needed a phone in order to
call the ambulance and
you know that sort of thing and they
said no no we don't want to phone him
here
phones are forbidden okay and he did not
accept that and he kicked him out of the
uh the congregation okay so he was out
and here's a fellow and he's uh he's got
a phone
okay a cell phone in fact and he hides
it
so that uh so that the amish don't see
it and since they don't watch tv they'll
never see this show so he's safe there
okay and the reason he's got it is
because he wants to listen to music he
loves the music
remember the amish and the mennonites
they don't have
music they don't chant they don't sing
there's no
singing no music whatsoever you would
die there yeah
this guy listens to music every second
you know
no music allowed in the mennonite and
amish communities
oh i guess uh you they you wake up the
devil
anyways uh so the guy likes it one
because he can
talk you know he can see things
right he can see shows and so on and the
main one is that
uh he's got um he's got music he loves
the music
he's enchanted with the music so are his
kids so they all gather around they say
okay nobody's watching let's listen to
music
[Laughter]
he's a devil worshiper yeah yeah yeah he
is
and he hides it even from his brother
who came to visit wait wait wait wait
how does he charge that phone
yeah i don't know i don't know way more
questions
yeah raises more questions or does he
have
internet i mean yeah
maybe he does but since the amish
wouldn't or the mennonites wouldn't know
you know how it's
connected in this house they probably
wouldn't know what he's got in there
um so what happens a lot of the new
breeds
okay they leave the uh the
religion or they become more liberal and
you see them driving
trucks okay and they drive uh wagons and
cars and whatever okay so
they have their own church they've
created new churches and you see
total differences between all these
mennonite and amish groups some some
like something some don't and they have
their own rules within their
each individual community how much
technology they allow us
yeah yeah essentially and uh the issue
is that they
the worry is that the world out there
the gentiles we
us you know the english as they call
them uh
they might you know uh they're they're
that we're the devil
and so it's kind of tempting uh them
with technology saying hey
guy would you like to have this
technology it allows you to do this and
that you can talk and
you know and you can ride your car and
so on they see that as an invasion
from the english speaking world it's
like the dave chappelle joke where he's
like in his car
on the highway and he sees the buggy
next to him with the with the amish
there
and he's like hey ezekiel where are you
going in that buggy
what huh i can't hear you hold on let me
turn this air conditioning down
this is tempting with technology yeah
and uh so
in their churches in these uh modern day
churches the guys who
are not so they're more liberal they're
not as conservative
okay they they even have a cell phone
they don't have a bible anymore they
read off of the cell phone
the bible so you can see the dangers
that they see to their culture
when the telephone invades them okay
so uh this is their this is their fear
okay
that's how powerful the smartphone is it
even got there
the smartphone it even got into the
amish yeah yeah it's so
powerful it just penetrates any culture
to use even even the pygmies in the
jungle yeah they don't communicate with
their sick with
smoke signals anymore okay and so what
happens
there's uh a group of people uh this is
a special case they talked about a
family and a group of others like seven
families
that were leaving uh their farms they're
beautiful farms
i mean farms that you would love to live
in you know everything's plowed you have
the
crops growing they have their house
their farmhouse the barn everything the
whole works they have the machinery
and these people are leaving all that in
belize
little country in central america
they're leaving all that
and going to the jungles of peru to
start
all over from scratch again and we're
talking about people who are around 50
maybe 45 50 years old so it's not like
they're 20 years old
these are older people and they're going
to the jungle complete jungle to the
amazon river
okay and they're going to the jungle
they're going to be cutting
the trees all over again creating new
land building their new houses again
all over they're starting all over from
scratch and they're doing it
because they see that some of their
neighbors
are embracing the new technology and
they don't like that they see
i guess the double within them and so
they're leaving and the interesting part
about that is
they're going this far away okay they're
going from belize which is a little
country there up
at the top in central america you're
going to panama city from panama city
they take a connecting flight to lima
and from lima they go to this place
called pukalpa
nobody knows about it okay and it's in
front of a river that
branches into the um amazon river
and uh what is interesting uh to get
there uh they have to
take an airplane and you see you see
these
mennonites oh really yeah going uh
by airplane you say well hold it why
don't they go with covered wagons
they even allow themselves to travel by
car it's just that they can't drive the
car but if someone takes them like a
taxi takes them to the airport that's
okay what
yeah someone's gotta take that they have
to have a designated driver
i can use a smartphone as long as
someone is holding it if i'm not
touching it
hey can you scroll for me i'm trying to
get to the next twit the next
tweet yeah so um okay and this is
this is the the jungle paradise to which
this
fellow is leaving his lands for amazing
that's it
okay that's that's where he's going okay
now one interesting thing about this is
that he says
that within the community the neighbors
you know they're all from the same
religion they're all they know each
other
they work together they're all expert
carpenters and farmers etc
probably metallurgic as well in some
cases i think some
i think some some amish don't accept
metal but
um they live uh together they know each
other they go to the same congregation
saying
listen to the same sermons etc they
built a house
in three days now it's not you know the
empire state building okay but i'm
saying they built a house a place where
you can
live in three days and
uh you know i'm sure a lot of folk
especially young folk
out there today they say oh i have no
place to live when will i be able to buy
my house
these guys buy a little bit of land they
work together three days they have a
house
it's no big deal for them it's just oh
house oh yeah somebody
and so that makes you stop and think
yeah they're well organized okay
they're not stupid people believe me in
that sense okay
at least they just prefer a simple
lifestyle yeah yeah
and it's uh uh in itself it's a
desirable life in many ways for many
people a lot of people would like to
have that
that freedom in the farm not only that
there's a lot of people that also go
into the woods to live
in a cabin and stuff like just there's a
lot of that
that wanting to live without not only
in nature but like just without so much
complication
that technology does bring in the rat
race yeah they're outraged you don't
want the rat race you don't want the
nerves
uh mental problems etc these people say
hey you know we live a peaceful life we
have a great life
uh they use the tractors instead of uh
the plows okay
they don't use cars they don't use
telephones they have some
trade-offs what do you think is their
view on physics of the world
do you think they're into i'll get into
that give me a second
i'm almost there you're saying they're
not quantum mechanics no no the issue is
that
uh i'll get to it in two seconds i'm
almost there okay
um what we have to understand about
these people uh when they
they're mainly you know since they came
from europe
in the 17th century that's the first
group that came over
um they were accepted especially first
of all in pennsylvania from there they
moved to ohio and from there they moved
to indiana and then spread out
to other states so most of them are in
those three states okay
two-thirds of the mennonites and i think
amish all those groups live in those
three states and there's one third you
know spread around
again colonization they went out and uh
conquered new lands so to speak
okay do they vote but so many questions
yeah yeah yeah okay
we'll get to that give me a second here
let me finish up with this and so this
is the issue the issue is
um they uh they've had problems
they have problems legal problems they
have been arrested
uh all for not following the rules white
man's rule english
the english as they call them okay
here's
them going to the supreme court they had
a supreme court case
why because they wanted uh to educate
their own children
you know homeschooling and the supreme
court
uh sided with them here but there were
you know all those cases are specific
and so they don't apply to everything
when a group went to nebraska nebraska
had some ordinance or some
local law or whatever and they
said no you can't educate your own kids
in your one school
one one room school houses okay and
they weren't able to win that battle so
they had to leave nebraska and go back
to indiana
or ohio or pennsylvania wherever they
were from
and here here you see the what i'm
talking about here's a schoolhouse
that's their school no college nothing
like that they only go
like to eighth grade uh 14 years old
that's it for the education then you go
back to the farm because farming
is their world okay so they learn the
three r's
uh reading writing arithmetic wow
uh i guess they know one plus one no
they automatically
no there's there's more than that
measuring is one but there's another one
which is
they they'd like money you know uh
forget it these are not completely
people who are
isolated entirely they have money they
use dollars i mean how do they pay for
their trip to go to
peru with dollars and and why because
they
sell to the english the people on the
other side of the river
they produce crops they sell them they
have their farmers markets and all this
other stuff
and they do like money and in fact uh
one of the
reasons the fellow went to peru was
interesting
to or whatever it's called um
he went there and he said you know it's
an ideal town for them
you say what this this four say god
forsaken place
and it turns out that there's 200 000
people living in that little
town in the middle of nowhere in the
middle of the jungle and what their idea
is
to sell to those people that's their
that's their market
they want to make money okay so they're
not completely
isolated from money and of course they
have what you could call economies of
scale where they have an advantage over
the locals
because the locals probably have gardens
and so there was this lady you know
she's alone
and she's selling i think it was apples
and she was selling them in the beach
well you know once these guys get
installed and they start doing their
thing they're going to beat all
all the competition because they're well
organized you know again there are many
of them working together they work like
a family
you know and it's maybe seven eight ten
ten families to start out with
eventually they'll be 20
30 40 100. okay in fact um
let me well let me cover another issue
one of
another reason they went to prison here
you see amish going to prison okay
these i think these are amish not not
the mennonites
they go to prison because they're
conscientious objectors
they are pacifists they don't want uh to
go to war
they are peace loving people they're
like mahatma gandhi okay
so here they're taken into prison
because they refuse to go to war during
the second world war
uh world war ii they do dress pretty
swanky i gotta say
yeah yeah i mean and you can see that
they're not handcuffed
and there's no guns pointing at them
they know these guys walk into prison
you know they're not dangerous at all
it's just that they're taken in there
because they refuse to go to war
okay that's the issue finally they let
them off the hook they put some laws out
there that
said uh they can do the military service
but in non-combat duties
and that's where they're at today okay
now the interesting part that i saw also
about this
is their population explosion that's got
to do a lot with my theory of extinction
okay just want to mention that in case
someone has questions today about that
and where is it
here this is their population
how it's exploded uh
17th century before 17th century the
1780 i think 1683 that's when they came
for the first time
and we're a few families so you can see
the the dots are on the bottom
uh very few hundreds we're talking about
hundreds
at most and then in the 20th century you
can see how that's gone up today there's
uh almost three hundred thousand
uh depending on one count uh i saw
another count half of that 150 000
but you can see that today we have
between
amish and mennonites all these groups
between 150 and 300 000 people
in the united states okay so you can see
the population has exploded and no
kidding
they have seven kids apiece so they're
large families all of them okay all they
do all night i mean there's no other
entertainment okay so you gonna feel in
the stick
and that guy with the hat the with the
cell phone
no no the biggest uh the biggest
entertainment there is playing tag and
hide and seek
that's more or less where it stands
today okay and so here are some of the
questions for you uh to ponder today you
can ask questions along these lines if
you want just to
stimulate your mind a little bit okay
and so these are the issues okay many
would like to be farmers and enjoying
more natural life
far from the hustle and bustle of
congested city i'm talking about us
everybody normal people the gentile or
whatever you want to call us
many are hostile too
and load the technological world
specifically related to food processing
husbandry you know how we grow chickens
and cows and
uh the antibiotics we put into them etc
etc etc
pollution vaccines coming up okay
around the world and health in general
people go to the hospital and they don't
trust the doctors etc okay
many would like to leave the rat race
and uh living community
in a community where neighbors help and
care for each other oh a lot of people
would love that
okay uh we don't see that we're all in
we're all in
million people cities and we're all
individuals
there's a million individuals we're all
hermits everybody's community
yeah there's no community you don't even
know who your next door neighbor is
these guys
you know they're 50 people maybe and
they all know each other and they go to
the same
church they work together they have to
build a house they do it if there's an
emergency they all work together
so here's the question you know with
those same individuals
who who who love all this stuff right
who would like maybe to join a commune
live in this communism okay
be willing to sacrifice their personal
way of thinking
and technology okay in exchange for the
good
of the community and here's some
examples these people use uh what is
known as plain dress so if you go there
for example you became one of those
that you would you may have to dress
like this okay
you see the girls and the uh guys the
dudes look cool
well the girls it looks like a
barbershop quartet over here yeah
and then uh and then um you know you
you might have to plow with your hands
yeah you have to have a beard and
to show that you're no longer a kid okay
uh you can buy a fake one i guess
no music no electricity no football
uh most exciting past time again tag and
maybe hide and seek
uh entertainment at sunday school that's
known as entertainment uh no cars uh
caveman dentistry and docs you know it's
with hammer and chisel
and uh no phone or internet and yeah no
beer and that that is uh it was good
until that last year yeah it's the one
that turned me off i said no i
don't know what you were thinking about
not the beer
when they said no beer i said no i don't
think i could take that
okay and because their populations have
expanded so fast
guess what be prepared for this they
went extinct
it's a microcosm of humans in general on
earth
okay here it is here's the graph uh
we're not the graph but i mean the uh
the two two big problems that they have
one is genetic disorders
hit amish hard uh this article came what
was it 2005
says the amish make up only 10 percent
of the population in
whatever county
county in ohio but they're half of the
special needs
cases three of the five miller children
for example have a mysterious crippling
disease
that has no name and no known cure
the three biler sisters were all born
with a condition that has no cure and
mysteriously leads to severe mental
retardation
and a host of physical problems last
year's doctors figured out the girls
have the gene
for something called cohen syndrome
there are only 100 known cases worldwide
and these guys have like 20 or 30 cases
now
of this since then more than a dozen
other cases of cohen's have been
discovered
in ohio uh amish country
they're also having um gays homosexuals
there's a site
known as lgbt amish wait how do they
have a website
yeah they they they had to leave the
congregation
they were kicked out they liked the life
over there but they were kicked out of
the community for being gay
homosexual whatever and so um
yeah again you might have to first on
the one hand you might have to sacrifice
your way of thinking your individuality
for the good of the community that's one
issue and remember how that's done
uh they choose a leader and that leader
uh
is the guy who's gonna uh kind of
you know take him by the nose and say
this is what we should do folks and
he kind of recommends but he's got a
group of people who who stand behind him
and so they impose that upon
their small community and they don't
their communities are not extensive each
community is maybe if
anywhere from 50 to 100 people you know
maybe
10 families or whatever how does that
work with the population boom though
every time they get to a certain
population branch they
branch out a lot of them uh migrate in
fact as you saw in the
effect i can put this up again uh where
was it
uh if i can find it
population this one here
you can see that um uh
you have the colonization phase which
was up to 1900 maybe
they were still having uh immigrants
and after that immigration stopped and
all that was the rest of it was
reproduction from the seed that was in
the united states so
all the people living today come from
maybe 12 000 6
000 individuals who in turn most of them
come
from the original families that came to
the united states
so you're talking about a founder's
effect and
since then you know you've got everybody
has the same grandfather
okay so so you know if you intermarry
no matter how many generations some
point is going to catch up with you
then you're going to start seeing some
of these genetic problems which is my
argument also for homosexuality that
it's happening today among uh humanity
because we've been inbreeding for 200
000 years
and we are eight billion but the others
are only like two
million in the on the planet total so
they're a drop of water in the global
population
but you can see where the problem is if
you have inbreeding for extensive
periods of time
you're going to come up with all these
genetic type problems okay
and so i think that's it's a good
indicator it's a it's a
good marker a kind of milestone
something to for you to gauge what's
going on out there okay
real quick yeah uh it's usually uh
correlated with their inbreeding that
they have
genetic disorders but could that also be
uh uh education no no like how they live
maybe that's why they have so many
generations
i think no one lives better than them in
that sense they have a very natural
life they eat well uh
they wake up with a rooster they go to
sleep with the chickens you know it's
like
they have a good life in that sense it's
a farmer's life it's a
very tranquil very peaceful life so they
have no i don't think they have any
nervous problems
over there like in the city you know so
i don't
think it's more than that it's just
genetic most of it
i don't know maybe there's another
factor the weather the the food i don't
think so but
yeah there could be some other issue but
i think it's primarily genetics
okay and this is the issue uh those who
know calhoun's experiment
uh you know you had also a founder's
effect
calhoun started with eight mice and
ended up with homosexuals and altus
at the end of his uh experiment
especially
universe number 25 and
uh you know this is just a father having
kids having grandkids get having great
grandkids and finally you know they're
marrying you amongst themselves and
what are you going to get out of that
you know it's a it's a colony that's
just
inbreeding constantly and that can't go
on forever
okay okay uh i'm going to answer some of
the questions some of the comments that
people made and then we open up the uh
uh
floor for for questions live questions
okay
let's go with the first one so let's we
so we move on here
okay a fellow says in relation to
prometheus the
story i told the other day about
prometheus giving fire to man and then
being punished by zeus
tied to a mountain let an eagle eat his
liver or his guts whatever
and this guy also raises the tree of
knowledge and you can also raise noah's
ark and some of the other
tales that you read in the bible and
other holy books
and he says is it not possible that the
ancients knew about the cycles of
civilizations
and a whole lot more and created these
allegories as ways
to educate generations that followed
okay well i can do is give you my
opinion
on that okay and that's that
uh i think all these fables came or
stories
tales they came when people you know
here you have shepherds
okay now how much education does a
shepherd have all he does is tend to
sheep every day okay that
that's what a lot of them did especially
in the middle east okay
nice weather they had these that was
their life
and so here they are maybe in the
evening you know around the campfire
maybe they've got the
the cattle or whatever they have out
there and they're looking at the night
sky and they see stars they don't know
what that is they say what is all this
you know where are we and so they
started
inventing stories and that were passed
on from generation to generation where
the guy said
well there was this guy named god and he
waved his magic wand and created the
universe another guy would say
yeah he created man and god he took some
mud
some clay put it together blew la life
into them
and the other guy said yeah and there
was this guy noah and he went with his
family you know on a trip and so on
so they came up with all these stories
and
added to that you know by the time you
get to the greeks uh you get
stories like prometheus and you know
there's a lot of stories
of the mythala greek mythology is very
rich in stories they're all great great
stories
okay but they had to explain certain
things and so they
introduced the gods and they said well
this guy did this and we had this other
guy the guy for the wind
he's the guy that blew your house away
and and so he didn't like you
you didn't pray to him or whatever so
they came up with all these stories
and again these people were not uh
they were intelligent for for what they
had to do for farming
for cattle ranch and that sort of thing
but they were not uh
sophisticated in a sense they didn't
have university degrees or
or the knowledge that we have have
accumulated today after
through decades and centuries they
didn't have that they didn't know what
electricity is
now they knew what magnet some of them
you know at some point they knew what
magnetism is because suddenly you know
they put their spear
or their sword close to a lodestone they
say oh
this this is attracting my my sword i
don't know why magic you know
the gods are talking to me you know yeah
i think they they were giving names to
the
reoccurring events that they kept seeing
like whenever they see
thunderbolts they give that that one oh
that's that god
yeah that's one of certain things war
war is that guy
but they didn't have a god of gravity
which to me is is astounding because
they realize that whenever they drop
something everything always fell to the
ground and they said i guess it was they
must have been
they must have asked them so why does it
go to the sky they must have asked that
question at some point someone must have
asked that question
and so they said well i don't know
because gravity is so fundamental
that you don't even you take it to
regret it's like breathing i think i
don't think that
dad didn't have a god for air either
yeah well yeah but not like breathing
it's like they're not
thinking on that level because there's
some things that are so fundamental that
you kind of don't even notice them
well that's why they they called it a um
what is it a one of the fundamental
elements because they couldn't see it
they could breathe it they say what am i
breathing what is going into my nose
that they must have or they move their
hands and they say oh i'm touching
something but i don't see it
so they must have asked these questions
for sure and they say well let's call it
air and that's what they called it you
know and uh
so i i don't think they had knowledge or
or at least
understanding okay what they had was
worldly wisdom on how to behave in
society and if you look at the bible i
mean i've read it three times
and what you'll see is how to behave in
society
you read the quran saying the exact
thing how you should
behave analogy yeah because they have to
invent stories and analogies and so on
or uh parables whatever like saying you
better behave like this because this is
what's gonna
god is gonna punish you what does that
mean society is going to punish you
that's god
you know if you don't believe like you
act like an [ __ ]
you're getting slapped yeah yeah so i
think it had to do with that
okay let me go with the next one here so
we move on and get ready to answer
questions uh one follows uh simple minds
understand simple things
genius understands complex uh
okay i think he missed one and i'm just
gonna add to that okay and i'm gonna say
and um irrational minds don't understand
at
all whether simple or complex
okay so um that reminds me of something
my brother keeps saying
whenever he sees me being happy with
something simple he's like simple mind
simple pleasures
and so here's uh here's the um uh
definition of irrational so we know what
we're talking about
we had to define the word irrational uh
so that people just don't
use it loosely and say oh you're
irrational why well because you don't
think like me
no no that's not the way it works that's
an opinion here we have some criteria
and uh just very briefly treating
concepts as objects number one
okay then you have using inconsistent
definitions or undefined
words theory inconsistent with the
assumptions that you put you put some
assumption then you you know
i always give the example briefly uh
the prosecutor presents
a gun and says and here's the weapon and
then his theory is about how the guy got
stabbed or how
he gets poisoned you know it doesn't
follow from what he presented which was
the gun
that sort of thing describing and
claiming to have explained
mathematicians do this all the time they
describe they think they have explained
something
now explanation description two
different things and then the mechanism
proposed doesn't work or cannot even be
imagined
particle at two places at once please
try to imagine that we're talking about
the same particle not a particle broken
in two okay we're talking about the same
particle
the cat your cat at two places at once
that's what we're talking about i mean i
guess if you can't imagine the
explanation then
that's who i understand
and that's what we call we call it an
irrational so that that those are the
criteria for irrationality so we have
objective criteria for what we mean by
irrational it's not an opinion
it's objective criteria okay let's uh
move on here
another fellow makes another common
question
he says
let me get it here could a shift in
understanding about electromagnetism as
threads instead of particles lead to new
inventions um i don't think so
the way i look at it um
we don't care about inventions science
is science and well yeah i know but
let's start there uh
science and science and technology is
technology technology has to do with
inventions
science does not have to do with
inventions now we have these threads we
we say look in in the case of magnetism
you got the threads a wall of threads
just
many walls of threads by the way you
know just spinning around the other one
in the other direction
that produces attraction and then they
go in the opposite direction they hit
each other and push each other away
knowing that assuming we certify or
believe
in it or whatever you want to call it
will that allow you to create some new
technology
we already can do a lot of stuff with
magnets without understanding
and we've done it for the last hundred
years without understanding exactly the
mechanism what is the
the invisible stuff that mother nature
has there here you have two magnets okay
there it is they stick together so
there's you don't see anything in there
do you
yeah between them no okay and see they
stick
you want yeah so magic okay and so
there's something there
and you got to identify that something
but that's science
but this part the fact that you say oh
it sticks together i think i can use
that for something
yeah i know i'll put it on the tv and
and hold or on a refrigerator
door and hold you know stick something
on there
so you can do that you can you can use
technology without understanding
the the foundation the the the
underlying mechanism
that's what i'm saying we do it all the
time i mean
electricity these guys don't understand
it they think it's a bunch of beads that
go from adam to atom
it's irrational we cannot even imagine
the atom that they're talking about
the planetary atom because we don't
understand why the electron beat doesn't
fly away or fall to the center of the
nucleus
to the nucleus of the atom so they don't
understand it
but they but they don't need to
understand it to to be able to do
something with
it that's the point if if i know that
you know i i let go of this ball right
and you know and it tends to go down
let's do it with this one
weighs less you let go the ball and it
falls on uh
always downwards but once you know that
you don't need to know what gravity is
all you need to do is hey
i know what i can do with this i can do
some kind of uh
technology with this knowing that it
always falls to the center of the earth
so what you need to know is the effect
you don't need to need to know the cause
the mechanism that's my point okay so
you're saying that since we have so much
technology without
knowing the actual causes mechanisms
mechanisms
we knowing the mechanism wouldn't give
us new technology but i would disagree
because the more you know about the true
nature of the world
it's just more clues that you can use to
build technology i'm not saying that
there will be new technology off of this
i'm just saying
any piece of information that lets you
navigate reality better gives you better
chances at building new technologies
i'll take it back he's not my smartest
son okay
okay let's go with the next question uh
comment
uh i hope you will produce a scientific
lexicon
we have produced one and i called it the
the foundations of physics okay
and looks more or less like this okay
and uh first of all we have to announce
what the golden prince of what i call
the golden principle which is physics
requires an object you can't do physics
without an object
so the first word you got to define is
an object or otherwise known as
something
and something that which has shape uh
opposite is
nothing so there are antonyms now you
can use these two words
uh consistently one is which that which
has shaped the other one is that which
doesn't have shape
we're done they're mutually exclusive
yeah in other words one has
shape the other one doesn't have shape
it's very simple uh concept distance
location exists in motion those are the
key words that you need to do
physics there's a couple others maybe
dimension
you need to know what straight means you
need to know what perpendicular means
angle that sort of thing but in general
those
are the key words that we need
to start physics you can't do physics
without those mainly because you're
bound to
end up using those words one right
you're gonna
at some point or other you're gonna use
those words and especially the word
something you need to know what
something is because you can't do
there's no phenomena occurring without a
something in there
and so when we see you know like we just
saw gravity and
magnetism and you say well i don't see
anything i can't touch anything there
that's not the definition of something
okay definition of something that which
i shape
whether you see it or not whether you
see it or not because it's not the touch
see touch criterion or criteria
it's uh it's shape does it have shape if
it has shape
it's something okay and so we have all
these somethings in nothing
and in is big word but we'll just use
that oh yeah
yeah yeah and we have something in
nothing meaning somehow
something cannot escape nothing because
nothing has no
border to cross that's what it means
it's not a container it's just that it's
a lack of container
so there is no border to cross see if
you're in a container
you're god well you can at least you
know almighty all powerful
yeah uh you can go through the container
because you're magical
okay no problem but if if there is no
container not even
god can escape if there's no wherever
because there's no
border to cross there's nothing you can
put your foot across and say oh i'm
finally out
there's no such thing yes technically
you're not in anything anymore right
that's why
that's why the end goes with quotations
you're in nothing
that makes sense yeah i mean in in that
sense just means that
um there is no nothing to cross that's
what
in means in that sense not in the sense
of container that it's got walls and
you can reach the you know you're within
the walls that's
the distinction there okay here's
another question
comment what do you get these uh
folks who watched the previous uh
shows and you know they ask questions
rational science is about ideas yeah
uh whereas empirical science is about
experiences connected to the real world
okay i thought rational science has to
do with the real world but okay
interpretation a hypothesis proposes a
tentative okay tentative
not certain or fixed provisional uh
done without confidence hesitant
explanation or prediction in other words
uh
follow says that a hypothesis is a an
explanation
or a prediction okay and the question is
whether an explanation and prediction
are the same thing
yeah i mean uh is it a prediction or is
it an explanation which one is it
because those two
are not synonyms that's the issue okay
uh and then the theory on the other hand
is a substantiated
explanation for an occurrence uh
theories rely on tested and verified
data okay that's just proof that means
you're going to be convinced of
something
and scientists widely accepted theories
to be true
true also is opinion what is true to you
is a lie to your neighbor
though not unimpeachable if it's on if
it's
uh unimpeachable or impeachable then
it's not true
i mean true means absolute truth i would
think right but the interesting
thing here is this fellow also gave some
examples
of what he was talking about and he says
the following he says um
he gives these examples and what they
are they're all mathematical examples
you know if you just read through them
real quick they all come from
mathematics
and the question is is saying that it's
an explanation or prediction
what's all this all these examples have
to do with what he just said
so that's the first issue i raised uh
none of his examples
when he uh gave have anything to do with
theory or with
explanation or even with prediction for
that matter they're just descriptions
mathematical descriptions
that's the first issue there's a second
issue
and uh and that's this
okay and it's um
again this is our rational scientific
method and here you can see the
difference with what he
proposed hypothesis is not a theory
it's not an explanation or a prediction
a hypothesis is an assumption
this is easy this is usually ninety
percent of the thing yeah
where all the bulk comes yeah yeah
because you got to figure out in the
case of uh
invisible entities what invisible
entities out there that's that's why the
assumption is important here
before we begin moving the invisible
entities what do what can we imagine
them to be like
right that's the issue and so the the
hypothesis includes the objects we
include also the definitions and the
initial scene
what is your movie starting from you
know what are the few
frames of your movie so that we can get
your starting point okay and then you
can explain your mechanism which is what
the theory is about and
again this is as applied to physics and
finally the conclusions
so uh you can see there's a difference
between what this file proposes
and what we're proposing okay then
there's uh this other issue
and that's that there's a difference
between an explanation and a description
okay an explanation is the causes
in the case of physics or reasons in the
case of philosophy underlying a
phenomenon
how or why a consummated event happen
an explanation deals exclusively with
the past
we science deals only with consummated
events
okay and described on the other hand is
a listing of properties of physical
objects and we use adjectives to
describe objects
and adverbs to describe or characterize
motion qualify motion and final issue
here there's one more
so let's get that one in there as well
and get ready for the questions in a
little while okay
and we don't do predictions in science
okay so
uh you're in the wrong forum fellow um
you gotta go see uh mrs
or uh you know the uh palm reader uh
gal with the crystal ball uh i think her
name is crew
casca and uh
you know she she's she's got at least a
fifty percent uh
uh rate in
success rate you know i mean so well
science is
almost unanimously equated with
making predictions and then having them
come true oh the suit must have must be
on to something because
something happened that didn't happen
yet that he saw coming so he must have
some
knowledge into the the ether
yeah but see that nature let me let me
show you that
uh example i always give that puts that
in in the proper light
you have an eclipse okay and
it turns out that you know the
mathematicians come to you and says
tomorrow at two o'clock there's gonna be
an eclipse
and two o'clock it happens there is an
eclipse
so far we have a description that's all
we have a prediction
is only a description now you say well
how did you know
that ah and the guy says well
what's he going to do he's going to have
to draw on his memory on his experience
we've had eclipses in the past he's
calculated those orbits etcetera and now
you say okay
one's due now you know haley's comet is
due after 75 years
why does he know that well he knows that
because he
you we call it a prediction it's not
really a prediction okay
in the sense that um in other words all
he's got is a description all he's
saying
he's not telling you why he's not
telling you the cause the mechanism
all he's saying tomorrow two o'clock you
know he could be guessing for all week
so you're saying a prediction
could be devoid of an explanation it is
and thus
if even if you make the correct
prediction
even if what you said comes to pass that
doesn't
necessarily mean your explanation of
what your
prediction was is even on point that's
not the point the point is in other
words if he can explain
if he can explain why it's gonna come to
pass he's joining an experience he's
he's talking about the past
he's talking about consummated event uh
he's explaining explanation you can only
explain
consummated events you cannot explain
what hasn't happened
that's the point the point is as soon as
he can explain it he's doing science
because now he's talking about the past
that's okay
predictions have to do with the future
they're outside the bounds of science
science only deals with consummated
events with things that happen that you
want to explain
you want to explain you know gravity and
you say why did the ball fall to the
floor
first you got to throw the ball or let
go the ball let it fall to the floor now
you have an event now you have to
explain it that's the way it works
but you can say well i can predict that
if i let go of the ball
it's going to fall to the floor well how
do you know that well let me explain
how how are you going to know that if if
you didn't have the experience to begin
with so the it has to have the
experience so the answer to
why why will that happen in two hours is
always because i've seen it before
and then from i've seen it before is
okay then let's explain
that right so uh and for that you have
to draw in your experience it always
gets delegated to the past eventually no
matter what
okay okay another
uh question comment here uh fella says
uh we can weigh the difference of a dead
battery in a charged battery it has mass
that we can weigh and here you have my
batteries uh
durabil and the uh there you have the
car battery the bill battery okay
uh i met you yeah i met your friend
did you spend on this picture but i
don't want to know
was it worth the joke
so i have my garage here i build these
things i sell them so if you need to buy
durabilts or the the car build battery
uh
let me know but here you're weighing a
battery okay so you weigh the battery
what have we learned about science so
so so i weighed myself before eating
i weighed myself after eating and
there's a difference
right and i'm sure there's a context
that's missing here
no no he says
he has more mass and less mass depending
on whether you weigh it before
or after uh it's charged or not charged
was he saying that that is
mass exists no but he's saying that
charge has mass
and so all he said is love has
intelligence that's all we
have this concept has this other concept
that's all you said so far so far we
have
no physics we have no physical entity in
front of us
what are we talking about what what
physical object what what has happened
what are we imagining
or what has happened yeah i mean what
event has that what do we have to
explain here
so just to describe and say look i i
weighed myself
and i don't want to tell you my weight
yet
and then i i eat three pounds of food
and then i weigh
a little more okay later on so okay so
there's a difference
what have i explained so far all i have
is
two descriptions a mathematical
description i weigh 195 away
195 uh pounds plus three more pounds
under 98. that's a lot of food yeah so
yeah if you can take it
so the question is or during the week
whatever i gained three pounds
the thing you explained is that you can
eat a lot yeah in other words
so far you haven't explained anything
all you did was give me a description of
a before and after mathematical
description
what have you explained i mean it's like
saying look the chair is white
but look i'm going to paint it brown now
the chair is brown
so we have before and after white and
brown and
what what have we learned well what is
it where's the science
that's the issue so so yeah the fact
that you can weigh
battery before and after charge doesn't
tell us anything you haven't told us
what charge
is what physical entity is this thing
you call charge
all we're saying or mass for them if
something changed yeah all you're saying
is something changed
mathematically because you you assign
you assign you you you put a standard
the kilogram the pound whatever you put
out there
and in terms of of that standard that
you created that artificial standard you
say
before it weighed so many kilograms and
afterwards it weighed more kilograms or
less or whatever
what have we learned all we did was
give a result in terms of pre-defined
standards
and we haven't we don't know why we
don't know the cause
why the battery weighs more what
happened what what penetrated a ghost
was it a spirit that went into the
battery when you charged it
does the spirit weigh three more pounds
now
okay moving on here two more issues and
then we're opening a
floor up for questions okay so get them
ready
we're going to go through the questions
people asked in a minute here
there is no scientific definition of
object that's what i said and he says so
why do you continue with the scientific
definition of object
is that which has shape well again
remember
what i just said and let me say one more
time
and that's that we have the foundations
of physics and
physics requires an object something
that the mathematical
so-called physicists have not discovered
in 10 000 years
you do need a physical object to do
physics you can't do it with concepts
you can't move energy you can't move
mass you can't move field around or
charge or
time or whatever you can't bend time you
can't
bend or move or weigh concepts
you can only way do that with objects
again if
we charge the battery it weighs more
then you got to tell me what charge is
what is this is this a ghost
a spirit what is this charge thingy okay
when you said there is no scientific
definition of object i'm sure your
meaning
there hasn't been one for the mainstream
science yeah and the main reason is they
had no
use for the word object for the word
thing for the word something
because they don't do physics with
objects
they've been using concepts and math
equations and concepts so they created
mathematical concepts abstract concepts
such as mass
energy field charge
force wave all these are concepts
and so they had to use concepts why
because they couldn't see
or touch the invisible entities that
mother nature uses
to do to run her shop and and
because of that they said well we can't
see it or touch it and we'll never
figure it out so let's not worry about
that let's just describe
mathematically what happened here from
the visible things
so if um if the air somehow pushes the
the chair right the gust of air comes
and pushes the chair over
you don't see the air you can touch it
but let's assume you can't touch it
either
for just for the sake of argument it
moves the chair you say okay
air hit the the the chair
i don't know what air is but i'm just
gonna
uh note how many yards
the chair moved what was the force what
was the energy what was the mass of the
chair
you know all those are descriptions you
still don't know what air
is and and until you visualize it
you will not figure out the mechanism
why the chair moved
okay all you're doing all you're doing
is describing
in mathematical terms using
pre-determined
in other words artificial standards such
as the kilogram
how much energy how many ergs or
whatever you're going to use
uh field charge you know 1.6 times 10 to
the minus 19 coulombs
whatever you're going to use in there
you're just going to describe it in
terms of those
units that we created you go to another
planet they have other units they won't
understand any of this
they don't know what a kilogram is yeah
you know land of the klingons
okay final question and or
issue i think same foul
just because we don't fully understand
electricity doesn't mean it's conceptual
well for that we have to define what an
object is and what a concept is
very simple and so object that would
just shape what is a concept a word that
invokes
two objects or embodies right uh or two
words
treated as objects for example motion
motion means a single object at two
locations so you treat that as two
objects because you're establishing
a relation between one location of the
object and another so you're treating
them as two out two distinct objects
uh you know and we have all kinds of
examples for that
so the point is that's a concept
anything that moves is a concept
does electricity move electricity
hopefully is a dynamic
concept therefore you know so it's not a
physical object you can't point to
electricity
because first of all it doesn't stand
still and second it involves
assuming you take the official version
and the motion of the
electron beat from one atom to another
that's electricity
that's a concept the objects are the
little ball that they're moving
the atom those are the objects the
motion the movie
of electricity that that's a concept i
guess a good example dynamic
is a good example for that would be fire
yeah where fire
there's something moving there but it's
really it's not it's not fire fire
yeah fire isn't a thing it's just the
the atoms that are
doing their combustion thing yeah and
now those are the real objects there's
no object called fire yeah
the object is oxygen the oxygen atom
okay or molecule okay and just in case
final here
final comment all words in the
dictionary can be placed under two
categories object and concept every word
in the dictionary
is either an object or a concept either
it designates that which has shape or
that which doesn't
why doesn't because it involves two
objects or more or two things two
two words that we're going to treat as
objects for example space and matter
okay
for universe objects we point to a name
concepts we can't point to okay we
define
so we don't define objects and we don't
point to concepts
point to love point to energy point to
mass and we'll know
what you're pointing to okay and then
you will see the word electricity all
the right there next to the last on the
right hand side so electricity is a
concept in fact
it's a dynamic concept isn't it easier
to define
concepts of z as that which doesn't have
shape
no uh i i don't think that's a good
definition uh why was it see if i can
remember why
i'll give you an answer that you you
stumped me i know there's a reason
we don't uh define it as that which
doesn't have shape for concepts
that's just that's just by the way
that's a good rule of thumb
okay when you go through the dictionary
you say okay
love does that have shape or doesn't it
can you imagine it yeah
it's it's black and white energy can you
imagine the shape now so
immediately as a rule of thumb that's
good uh as a first line of attack
to say that's a concept that's an object
the correct uh
definition is um
a relationship that's a synonym but uh
it's a word that invokes two objects
because you're essentially
making a comparison a relationship
between two objects
no matter what concept you look at and
again you can test it with all kinds of
concepts and that's the challenge there
you know
find me a concept that does not involve
two objects uh real quick in which one
of those oh you got one yeah
in which one of those categories does
space fall under
space nothing okay and uh
yeah we say that um space
is an antonym of object first of all
that which has shape that's one issue
and then the other one is yeah it
doesn't have shape
for sure it's not an object but is it a
concept it's a concept because the
concept is nothing
the concept is nothing but it's not a
relation between two objects
uh in a way it is because you're
comparing it against the
object the matter of the universe is an
object
yeah there's a loophole there could be
okay i got to think about that a little
more good so he's not the most
intelligent of my kids he's just
i'm the most annoying i just like
getting under people's skin
okay let's begin with the questions uh
put my son to work today
uh it's not that many questions i got
more questions about the amish but
okay yeah anything goes okay so you
handle that now
good evening lightness said there was uh
300 years ago the
stars have evolved into planets i mean
questions
there weren't that many questions okay
or what do you think i saw one somewhere
in here
well don't go through all of them uh so
quick yeah here uh why am i conscious
right before the extinction is conscious
consciousness emergent i don't know what
that means
is consciousness emerging uh
consciousness
is not a physical object essentially we
deal primarily with
objects here so consciousness is a word
that belongs to religion
okay anyone using the word consciousness
i know for sure has a problem with
religion
ashkenazis apparently descend from 950
individuals they have around 90
unique genetic disorders such as tay
sachs
very very likely yeah because again
small communities tend to have those
kinds of problems
if they if they inbreed you know i'm
gonna hold my breath what happens my
breathe
sorry
it's going down scrolling down scrolling
down
trying not to skip any questions yeah
they're pretty much here
the newest ones
how does nothing weigh something in the
difference of battery charged versus
uncharged
well uh what you have to identify is
what physical object i mean we can call
it charge we can call it energy we can
call it mass we can call it whatever we
want
the issue is what are we talking about
can we draw
the thing that went in there what went
into the battery that's what you got to
explain
and for that if you're the presenter
you're the guy giving the dissertation
you got to tell the crowd look this is
what i say is in there that's what went
into the battery that's the issue the
issue is
you know i don't care if it's uh if it
suddenly has more coulombs
in there you know uh so now we have more
charge
so who cares about that i mean the
question that's a mathematical
description we need to find out what
spirit what ghost
went into the battery that's the key
that's where science comes in because
now you have to break your brain and say
okay
let us assume this charge thingy
is this thing here and you point to it
you draw it you bring it you
to the conference um
you you make a mock-up mock-up
of it and maybe you bring a ball you say
look
this is charged this is what went into
the battery okay so how do you go well
it went in there like this and now you
explain the mechanism that's science
but to say that you know the battery now
weighs more
well it's going to like say i eat food
and i weigh more okay
i was going to say that any time
something weighs more that means
something went into it but it gets
tricky because of velocity which also
mimics weight but we're talking about
mechanics here make a mechanical process
where you say
you know if i ask you how did the box go
up you say i pulled the rope
through the pulley and that's how i
pulled the box up since you see all the
objects you understand it even a baby
understands that
but uh if you just do the thing without
the
rope you say how did the box go up you
said oh it was magic
it was energy it was charge uh
what are we explaining with that we
can't see the objects we need to see the
object
you have to be able to illustrate make a
movie of your theory
if you cannot you're not doing physics
you're doing maybe math but not
physics physics is with physical objects
can you explain ropes and frequency
that is used every day
can you can you explain ropes in
frequency that is used every day
oh yeah in fact i think i've done that
several times now
uh i don't know if there's a new guy
here's a rope okay
frequency is the number of uh links
so let's say how many do we have there
maybe two
three maybe three okay now we untorque
it
okay that's a bad problem you can barely
see it but yeah
and now you have maybe two links and
each one is longer
so the reason and it's related to the
wave equation little c which is a
constant the velocity of light
okay uh 300 000 kilometers per second
rounding off
and what is that equal to frequency
times wavelength when the frequency goes
up the wavelength goes down
and the rope mimics that perfectly i
mean
that is the equation of a rope why
because when the
frequency uh in other words the number
of links
is uh are many then
each each link is smaller is shorter and
vice versa when the links are greater
for the same amount of rope
you know you have fewer links that's it
that's that's the relationship of
frequency to light
through a rope do you still think a
square is a standalone object
uh yes uh if i have only one if god
all he made is a square in the universe
i don't know how he made it how you made
it
sit there i don't see the back of it
because as soon as you turn the square
it becomes a rectangle so it's got to be
straight forward to me
right that's the only way you can see a
square and
if that's the only object god made he
said what is that bill
that's a square okay that's it that's
the only thing that anyway that means
you're there and god
yeah something's off spirits okay so
yeah square is a standalone object in
other words i don't need any other
object to understand the word square
now square let's keep in mind square is
only a face of a cube or a rectangular
shape of some kind okay so it's one of
the ends one of the sides
we call that a square but we don't need
the cube i don't need to see the rest of
the cube
to understand the word square that's not
the case with
for example the uh halo of an angel
if if the angel is not there that's a
ring or a plate
right if i want to you call that a
a halo i need the angel because that
that makes it holy that makes it a halo
okay interesting maybe you should call
people love instead of people
then you could point to love
okay i'll point the low uh that's bad
that's my though wait what about
water water doesn't have shape neither
does gas
not true in fact uh if you look at the
one of the two videos that i put up one
of the five videos i put up there
i show that that is the case uh anything
made out of atoms
is um uh s shape
anything well i guess i mean not so much
the the thing that it's made of but the
atoms themselves do have shape
first of all this is the amalgamation of
the atoms that we call water
but but but this is the issue when we
point to a table
we treat it as a single piece when we
say table we're not thinking
oh a table's gazillion atoms no no so is
an elephant so is a rock
a tree everything is gazillions of atoms
me i'm a gazillions of atoms
so we're all the same are we gonna just
talk about what everything is made of
so we don't say oh a table is gazillion
atoms no we say a table is that what i'm
pointing to
okay that that shape we treat it as a
single piece
objects like just like the square we
don't say what is the square made of
little squares
no no we don't care about any of that we
say that's a square the word square
refers to that image that i see in front
of me
and this is no differently uh no
different
you see a an object
and for example or you don't see it like
in the case of gas
or in the case of water you see it but
you say well it's
amorphous it has no real shape yes it
does have
shape what shape do you want me to give
it if the
the question is not what is the shape of
water the question is
does it have shape it's a yes or no
type of question if the astronaut
releases
a blob of water in the middle of space
there is no container okay it's just
floating there
that blob has shape you may not
understand the shape you may not be able
to describe it because it's an irregular
shape
that blob has shape what is the shape of
the blob that's a separate issue
but the blob has shape water has shaped
so does air
and air around our planet has the shape
of a shell
of a cloud it's a spherical cloud that
envelopes our planet envelopes
envelopes envelopes envelopes
if bill thinks that we are the last
generations of human on earth why would
he father
me because i did it before understanding
that
he figured that out later yeah yeah i
don't think i'd have him
especially after today i don't think or
anything would you have bothered me
if you had figured it out first uh i
don't think so
i think i would have maybe i would have
thought differently how's the bullet
there
i'm glad you're done
[Laughter]
would a tornado count as a physical
object
no they can have a pretty clear shape no
no
remember tornado is is that a
stand-alone object there is no
object stand-alone object called tornado
tornado means
moving air hurricane means moving air
moving air air is the object here is
what is going to move you first have to
take the snapshot of the object in this
case
air then you can do whatever you want
with it you can do tornado with it you
can do
you know uh hurricane but then what's
the difference between tornado
fire electricity and table
let's stick with tornado what's the
difference if a table has a shape but
it's just an
amalgamation of i haven't moved atoms
yeah yeah but no it's not a
amount a table is not an amalgamation an
aggregation of atoms a table is what i'm
pointing to but what's the difference if
you see a tornado
because the turn the word tornado refers
to something that's twirling
there is no tornado that's just standing
still like that's an ice cream cone so
you have something
against the motion of yeah the motion of
fire the motion of other
motions it bothers you see you see if if
i have uh stand up if i take a snapshot
of a tornado i have an ice cream cone
but then i feel
but then is there some something missing
in the definition of object
because then we're not just talking
about shape we're talking about motion
because you're excluding
objects or you're making a distinction
between objects that have their shape
simply because of their motion and
objects that have their shape even if
they're standing still
yeah and that's why let me show this one
more time so that we put it in the right
context
okay and let me put it on my it doesn't
matter here
uh something is the first word you have
to define you have to define
what a thing is what an object is etc
where does the word
motion come in right at the end why
because you need
two objects okay two objects or one
object at two or more locations that's
essentially what we're saying
okay so first you can't define the word
motion before you define the word object
not in science not in
physics first you have to define what a
thing is then you can start moving it
and talk about motion because the word
motion means
two or more locations of one object is
it confusing
when you're talking about objects that
have shape because of their motion
no it is computers you say you're saying
you're saying
we exclude the the motion objects
because
that kind of muddies the the
conversation first of all that then you
get
one guy told me one day this was a
chemist okay listen to this
kim has told me that objects are made of
motion
oh yeah and that's what you say though
yeah i mean what is strange
what is string theory string theory says
there's a 1d
line i can't imagine that but let's
let's go past that
and they say that a particle is the
vibration of the 1d line
in three directions because i guess the
particle is a ball
i don't know so they're saying that the
particle is a vibration of a
line that's what that's what strength
theory has today so
the particles of quantum mechanics
according to string theorists
are made of motion
that's the problem i read a few days ago
that dark matter is made of axions
axions is that a new detergent
commercial uh what was it dark matter
dark energy
dark matter is made of axions yeah
axioms is again a concept
dark matter is simply a variable that
they had to create they had to invent
the mathematicians had to invent
to explain the rotation of a galaxy
because they said look
the stars on the outside are going just
as fast or faster than the ones on the
inside how do you explain that
well you can't explain it with newton
and you cannot explain it with einstein
neither of the two equations work so
they had to modify the equations
and to modify the equations meant
they had to sprinkle kilograms
on the outside of a galaxy to make it
twirl like they all twirl
with the stars on the outside going just
as fast as the ones on the inside track
that's the problem so dark matter is
simply
a mathematical contraption an invention
that they made
to fig to fix a problem and the problem
was understanding
why a galaxy twirls like a twirls and
right now they don't have an answer for
that they're looking for
dark matter through their telescopes or
whatever you know and they're never
going to find it because they're looking
for a ghost
if frequencies are ropes winding and
unwinding
i guess threads yeah uh does resonance
happen
those resonance i don't know what the
res
i'd have to look at the context uh
resonance others
you know it just means that one area
influences another one
okay so i don't know i'd have to look at
the context gas is a concept
of molecules i guess the earlier thing
saying that gas is i guess they're
equating gas with tornado
gas is a physical object what's the
difference between gas and tornado
gas i can take a gas like air
in fact that's that's is the issue i can
take a chop
i can chop or let's do it like i always
say
you have um an astronaut okay
and he puts air into a balloon maybe he
blows the balloon
right he takes it to outer space okay
and let's color code the air so that we
can see it just just for the sake of
seeing it that's that's the only purpose
of color coding it he pops the balloon
what comes out of there is a gas we call
that
specific gas we call it air okay so in
that sense
they're synonyms okay
what came out of there is a blob it's a
blob that is expanding
you take you film it you look at any
frame of that film
and and you'll see a blob you'll see a
shape
an irregular shape for sure and it's not
contained there's no container
because it's space space is nothing so
that blob is just expanding or
or floating away and it's an irregular
shape
so air does have shape all those atoms
put together
are no different than the atoms put
together to make a table
they're the same thing so we don't say
oh a table is
is not an object yeah we say a table is
an object so why is an
air an object why isn't water an object
if they are also
made out of atoms is it because they're
fluid is it because you would make a
distinction between water and whirlpool
yeah for example this is very simple and
it's not it's it gets tricky because
shape but we're not talking about the
world before we're talking about the
water which is a combination of atoms
the most when you add the motion that's
when you have a problem with the word
let me give you a rule of thumb just a
rule of thumb okay
okay take a snapshot
of whatever air uh water
can you take a snapshot of water is
there a shape
in your picture yeah that doesn't work
because if you take a snapshot of a
whirlpool
the world no but that's not but you
can't call it a whirlpool because
whirlpool means
embodies the word motion yeah that's
that's the problem
but you can take a snapshot of water
when it's not moving when it's
completely still if you can make it
completely still
you can take a picture of that and say i
got a shape there we'll call that water
so water is a physical object air is a
physical object all gases
are physical objects but tornado
whirlpool fire and electricity are
concepts because they
include the motion it embodies motion
that's why
fire is not an object uh none of those
are
that's a good clarification to make then
where can people find the
scientific dictionary that you use
uh that you'll find it uh where do i
have that um
is there a website uh yeah i know i have
a
uh i've got a link like a glossary yeah
i've got a glossary but
uh again um i'd have to look it up
yeah there is one i'll i'll post it uh
next time around okay
i'll post a link uh to it uh foundations
of physics
and they include them primary terms
you'll find them on my website
uh why god you know what is it this
one's called uh
uh what is it einstein's idiots
if you go in there you'll find on the
first page you'll find
the one of the first links will give you
the
key words necessary to do physics
are 2d things objects yeah
two-dimensional three-dimensional comes
later we have objects which exist
objects which don't exist objects we
which exist are not all 3d because
a table is 3d but the table i'm
imagining
is a table also because the word table
always here and on the other side of the
universe in the land of the klingons the
word table
means object always it's always an
object now the one that i'm memorizing
the one i'm thinking about that one
doesn't exist
the one that exists the one i have that
i'm pointing to this one outside that
one exists
but the one i'm imagining the one i drew
that one doesn't exist
what exists is the pencil the paper the
yeah but and the one that i'm imagining
doesn't exist either it has
no location in order for for something
to exist it must have location
god wants to exist he better have
location it's not enough for him to be
an object say look i'm
i'm a magician here here's my magic wand
i guess i guess imagination is what
we makes everything weird because
technically speaking
all objects that have shape should be
the ones that we have in existence but
since we can imagine things we can see
the shape
that isn't here that kind of confuses
everything
yeah and the problem there with to
follow up on that
the problem there is we also so can
imagine or or think about or
conceptualize concepts like intelligence
love and imagine their shape no no you
can't imagine their shape but what i'm
saying is
that's where we get them mixed up
because we say well if i can imagine
love
there's no difference between the table
that i'm also imagining
and it turns out that the word table
refers to an object whereas the word
love does not
it refers to a concept and so that's why
you have to be very careful
and you have to define these words very
pers you know the categories like object
very precisely because otherwise you're
going to be crossing the line back and
forth and
get lost you're going to be chasing your
tail around now you have to define them
very clearly what is an object what is a
concept
if a shadow has shape does it have
something or lack of something called
light
everybody asks the same thing uh
hologram
shadows hologram is a 3d shadow
that's light it's a dependent object
it's not a standalone object in other
words
if i remove the light there is no
hologram if i remove the light there is
no shadow
the guy the joke not me for example
or a shadow of a tree the tree is the
object the shadow
is light shown through or across
red because uh the the object are the
ropes that
mediate light but the shadow is
is a dependent object without the tree
there is no shadow
what do we mean by when we talk about
standalone objects i've heard that many
times today
standalone by that i mean that it's not
a dependent object that i
that should be the only object in the
universe in other words the word square
is a standalone object in that sense
that i don't need
any other object to see the shape in
front of me
i can just put a square there and say
square that's the only object in the
universe i haven't started
creating other objects yet i'm god you
know and i'm gonna make a square and
that's where i start then i'll make a
circle and make others
right now all i made is a square that's
the only object and i don't need any
other
object for the words square to
understand the word square square is
that just imagine the word square
you don't understand also also yeah but
what i'm saying is
you have to first name the object
that you're going to use in your
dissertation and in this case i'm going
to use the word square for whatever
and i say square that's the object okay
what are you going to do with that well
i'm going to make it fly around or
whatever
okay i'll deal with that later right now
all i'm doing is presenting the object
and giving it a name so that e.t not
pointing to you
uh so that he understands my language
right now i have to identify the object
i'm going to use in my theory
that's the issue i think that's what
gets hard to understand in all your
talks here on
on the on the stream because
all of this becomes hard to digest when
devoid
of the presentation because you talk a
lot about the rules of a presentation
but you don't really understand why
there are so many rules for a
presentation because there are no
presentations
like there's no one here giving a
presentation that you can be that you
can criticize and be like oh you made a
mistake here you made a mistake there
for everyone to understand
uh this is the issue the issue is that
what is science
what is physics physics science is about
explaining
you're going to explain so you're giving
a dissertation every time you explain
something even if you explain why the
bottle
babies bottle fell on the floor whatever
you explain in life
you are giving a dissertation so
you now you're talking to an e.t the et
comes
he doesn't understand your language so
you got to teach him your language first
you got to say
this is the bottle okay this is the
nipple this is the baby
this is the high chair so
first you got a point name and name the
objects now you can explain to him what
happened if he understands the rest of
the
language right you can say look the
bottle the baby
hit the bottle and fell on the floor now
you can explain what happened
first you need the objects first you
need to identify all the objects in your
movie and the one you're going to
explain
an explanation is a movie physics
explanation of physics is a movie first
issue identify the objects you need to
know what the objects are you can't say
let me explain gravity to you and you do
not
identify the object that's going to
mediate gravity
what are you going to understand as far
as the mechanism
that's the issue the cause how would we
describe or define
a 2d thing uh we can't think
no no but do you point to it yeah i mean
it's just a naming
it's uh pointing the same circle
triangle
square so that the other person can
understand can
imagine the shape that you're imagining
you can even draw it or bring one to you
know a little picture or whatever
you point and you name triangle i don't
need any other object in the universe to
understand what a triangle is all i need
is for you to point a name and say
that's triangle
that's certain i understand if you're
explaining it to me then at any time you
say triangle i know
i can imagine the correct shape right
then you look at the so the et says okay
every time he
mentions the word triangle he's
referring to that thing that he just
pointed to
that's all it is so you present the
objects that you're going to use to
explain your theory of
physics and it better be an object
hopefully not a 2d
object by the way because you know we
don't need those all i'm saying is
the word triangle if you look it up in
the dictionary it's one of those things
that has
shape therefore it goes under the word
object because the only
criteria the only specification that you
need
to fall under the category called
objects is
shape you don't need to be able to touch
it you should not be able to
see it you don't have to imagine it none
of that all you have to do does it have
shape yes
it's an object done have you read
einstein's mistakes
by hans orhanian no i haven't read that
one but i know a lot of einstein
mistakes that's for sure
i could write a book on that myself are
you saying there's no
agreed upon dictionary only the one on
your website that you can't remember
uh the problem is that for the last ten
thousand years the so-called scientists
have not defined
words scientifically especially those
who claim that they're physicists
they're really mathematical physicists
they have not defined any of the words
of physics they have not defined what an
object is
they don't know what motion is they
don't know what distance is
and and this is the challenge for you
grab any
any textbook of physics high school
college see if any of them begin by
telling you
this is an object this is what motion is
this is what distance is
no what you'll find is already distance
traveled and
from there on they talk about mass as if
you know what mass is
they talk about force one of the first
things that you learn in physics
high school is force equals mass times
acceleration and they start by saying
this is how
uh they weighed the earth how did we
figure out
how much weight the earth has and they
show you the calculation
so they're immediately into math they're
into talking about force
mass acceleration they're talking about
things
you know concepts but not at what point
do they say look
for the rest of this book this is what
an object is this is what location is
this is what distance is this is what
motion is
you'll never find it in fact uh go go to
newton
uh who started this whole thing and in
his scolium
uh he says very clearly i don't define
blah blah blah space and motion because
we all know what it is
it's like we don't need to define it
because we all know what it is right
where are you going to take the trouble
to define it
that's where he made the ear yeah in
physics we need to define those things
you had to put the square that makes
that makes it not stand alone
there aren't any squares you can point
to stat stand-alone
earth i can't point to earth square i
can i can't point to square
square standalone means it doesn't
depend on any other
object i can have a square all alone
that's all that is weird
it's the word it's the word square the
word
square is what stands alone the word
the word the word um halo
requires the angel it's not a standalone
object the word square stands alone the
word cube stands alone
i don't need any other object to see to
say
that's a cube and i point to it and
that's a cube it stands all alone i
point to a square it stands alone it
doesn't mean it stands alone there
it means the square floating in space uh
square floating
space now it's just the word square
refers to that image in front of me
that's what standalone means i don't
need to have an
angel next to the square to point to the
square i think we're gonna have to have
a test
we're just we're just gonna go through a
list of words yeah that's gonna happen
which one
is an object which one isn't yeah and
that's what they're doing now they're
they're trying to figure out well is
that an object
it's a trial and error right no square
triangle it doesn't matter i don't need
an angel next to a triangle
to for the word triangle to designate
that shape i do
need the angel if i say that's a halo
because the word halo requires an angel
requires
holiness i can't have otherwise it's
just a ring or a plate
that's the word that word would be plate
or that word would be ring
if i wanted to i want to call that halo
i need the angel i need to put the angel
right underneath it or the wings for
that matter as well you know
to say somewhere how long we've been
streaming yeah
okay i don't know if you want to make
this last question or keep going can you
point to a square without drawing it
it's irrelevant totally irrelevant
if someone if i come across a wall i say
wall
if i come across a square i see a square
that that the word square is what's used
to designate that shape
i don't need to come across a in we're
going to be able to wear a square for a
while puffs
square on paper versus square in a box
in front of you
same thing we need we didn't really
figure the square thing look
uh if no astronaut no
astronaut has ever come across a square
in space
because squares are objects that don't
exist
squares are objects that don't exist
why because they're two-dimensional and
you need three-dimensionality first and
second it has to have location
the three-dimensional cube i'm thinking
of
is an object but it's an object that
does not exist
it doesn't have location the table i'm
imagining is an object
but it's not it's an object that doesn't
exist because i'm imagining it
the the real table the one that exists
the one that has location
and you have to distinguish so it's it's
the words you got to understand
[Laughter]
if you got a square it's like a little
bit tilted
no if it's tilted it's a rectangle
there's no such thing as a tilted
square
and and a tilted circle is an oval
always
i guess that's that's it for the
questions for the first
the enemy beat the squares to death here
man there's a lot of um square questions
no no there's a lot of
i guess nuance when we're trying to talk
about the shape
shapes but they're only shapes and
motion shapes but there
are words that that are only that shape
given another object like angel yeah
yeah yeah relation to the language
stand alone so so so it isn't as
straightforward as
shape is object in a lot of cases
because you kind of
exclude things that have motion exclude
things that are that
simply because of something else so
there are certain things that you do
exclude
as far as shape is concerned let me give
you a for instance
based on that i'm imagining a square or
a cube it doesn't really matter i'm
imagining this
object okay so i i imagine i
s i see i visualize the shape square
or cube i guess we all know what a
square is what a tube is fine
i'm imagining it we need it does that
square that i'm imagining
the only thing i'm imagining in in the
darkness of my mind i only see a square
does that square move
and the answer is no if i'm imagining
only one
square that square does not move okay
and yes uh there it is there's a square
i don't need to see it on paper
because i know what the word square
means it's i've already had experience
with it so i say well i know what a
square is you know four sides are all
equal blah blah blah
okay so i imagine it there's a square
i've created the square
in my mind does that square have motion
does it move no because there's no
nothing that i'm comparing it against
it's just
a square in the darkness that's all it
is that's god creating a square out of
his mind
and saying hey bill spirit bill do you
see that yeah
because we can't we don't count right
yeah yeah because if if i
if i'm more than a spirit then i'm an
object ah there's two objects
no squares don't move so you're not
going to run across them first because
they don't have location
what is motion two locations so no
uh you don't run across squares
that doesn't make it a non-object you're
saying there are no squares
that exist right there are squares that
don't
there are no squares that exist and no
ideal
geometric figures that exist at all
they're all imaginary we can draw them
we can
you know do no fingers exist at all
no figures exist there no no no figures
exist but irregular in other words
they're not
perfect cubes you don't have a perfect
cube in real life but that's not the
point
uh no but then it's not a cube even if
you have an irregular shape the shape
doesn't exist
it's the object that looks like the
shape
like like if i have a pyramid or
something even if it's an irregular
pyramid
the pyramid itself doesn't exist the
shape pyramid it's the
it's well yeah yeah again
we have to distinguish between ideal
geometric figures
and those that we build if you look at
the i don't know the uh
the pyramids in egypt we call them
pyramids are they perfect pyramids
obviously not they're very irregular
when you come
close to them you see that they're not
perfectly
perfect uh smooth perfectly smooth etc
if you go into detail with adam forget
it you know it's not smooth at all
you go to the sun it's almost a perfect
sphere i mean if we could go in there
and really look at it from
every corner right we would say this is
a perfect sphere
well it's not even perfect because
there's one atom here one out of
there they're out of alignment they're
not perfectly it's not a perfectly
smooth sphere the bigger the sun or the
star
perfect maybe it approaches perfect uh
perfectly spherical object but it never
gets there because
atoms uh make sure that you know
their ones off by a little bit it
already makes it
uh not perfect the only way you can get
a perfect geometric figure for which we
use these words such as sphere
cube etc is imagining it that's the only
way you can do it you say okay i know
what you're talking about
and we use those as adjectives oh that's
spherical that's cubic
and so on but uh does that mean it's a
perfect cube a perfect sphere
no we just use that as an analogy as an
approximation
but isn't it correct to say that a
square in any case
is a concept because
there is no square there it's just your
it's a relation between the uh the atoms
of the
ink that make the square yeah uh
there's a fine line we have to be aware
of that if you're comparing
you have a concept okay and when we say
square
we're we're kind of distinguishing it
from
circle and triangle for example so we
say well
that shape we call square that one there
we call triangle that one we call circle
they're the set uh it belongs to the set
of geometric figures right
two-dimensional geometric figures but
that's not the point the point here is
that
i can point to a square and call that
square i can call it x for all i want
you know i can call that x i call it
square because uh you know i know the
word
i could call it x but whatever i call it
if i call it square
i don't need the triangle and i don't
need the circle
to compare the square against and say
well
this is a square what do you mean square
well because it's different than a
circle
because then i'm introducing another
object and that means i'm going to have
a concept because i'm comparing it
comparing them now if i point to a
square
only and that's the only object i'm
imagining that's the only one god
imagined in the universe and he allows
me to see it somehow
and i look at it and i say okay that's a
square or he tells me
from now on uh this is going to be
called a square
and i saw that it is good
okay that's the way it works so you i
don't need to know
circle or triangle to understand the
word square refers to that
object again i can call it x
so it's it's a question of defining of
of making sure that the words
that that the objects have a word
assigned to them you have to name the
objects that
just like adam you know uh god put him
on garden of beating and then he put all
these animals say okay name them and the
guy said okay elephant
turtle i guess again like i said earlier
this becomes more
apparent when someone's actually giving
a presentation if we had an
example of a presentation you can kind
of point out the step by step of
of of the process of giving a
presentation
why he has to define his words what goes
wrong if he doesn't define his words or
what could go wrong
how someone could misunderstand
something if they don't have the exact
definition
the how the nuances can break it down in
someone's understanding
all of this is kind of not
as clear if we don't have a guy giving
you a presentation because you're giving
all these rules
and and exam and basically rules
and and and truisms i guess but they're
all in a vacuum
like well they're not in a vacuum in
this sense in the sense that
science physics is about giving a
dissertation
explaining something so that's the
concept that doesn't because
it doesn't become apparent until someone
gives a presentation where it's like oh
that's why you have to define yeah
and that's when you don't want to
confuse ordinary speech because ordinary
speech we say
hey pass me the table well
what are you talking about is it this no
that's a chair i'm talking about that
other object
so it doesn't matter there because you
don't have to be precise
does the does love exist well yeah for
me it doesn't exist well that's ordinary
speech
in physics you have to be very clear
because do you mean by exist
what do you mean by object you have to
be clear because you're giving a
dissertation to someone else
who has a different understanding of the
word
the et he comes over he's got a
different idea he doesn't know your
language at all
and so you got to say look this is a
square this is a
a cube let me tell you what i'm going to
do with it this is what i'm going to
explain with it
so it's got to do it's got to be in the
context of an explanation
because that's what physics and that's
what science is it's explaining a
mechanism
you cannot explain a mechanism without
an
object that's the issue
i guess that's it okay you can still
write questions we'll look them up
and whatever we don't answer now we'll
look it up
if you put questions here we missed you
don't worry we'll
we're copying the questions and we go
through them say okay we'll answer this
well and so on
okay then we'll see you next time uh
what is it on wednesday
and hopefully i'll see this gentleman uh
sometime at the end of february
i bring him here with a gun i'm the boss
fight yeah he's
he's the boss i gotta behave here
because every time he comes around i
gotta
obey him he's like god
we'll see on wednesday